hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game and this is a really
wild game from the final round of the
2018 LT Box Norway Championship this
time between the Fabiano Caruana and
Wesley so and if we check out the
standings after round 8 let's just have
a look at it we had a four player time
Magnus Carlsen with Lisa Nakamura and
Fabiano Caruana and now for Fabiano who
has the white piece and Wesley so in
this game if they win this game since
this is the final game that was played
in the last round if Wesley wins then
Wesley wins the tournament if Fabiana
wins then Fabiana wins the tournament if
you've seen in my previous video and the
one that a very nice game against Sergei
kurakin and Hikaru Nakamura drew his
game against chakram Omidyar off and
magnus carlsen drew his game in the
final round against max impartial a
graph this is the final game that's
being played
Fabiana Caruana versus a vastly saw so
let's see it yeah we do have a couple of
photos of this matchup here is one photo
from the live feed and we do have one
photo from the from the official web
page so let's you know enjoy it for a
brief moment and then we continue with
the game and if any of you are following
the were following the official coverage
by Cena Magazine Rudolph then I'm sure
you all know everything about the the
special Norwegian water they said they
were talking about it was quite
extensive so let's check it out Fabi has
the white pieces and he opens with E for
just a second there okay efore we have E
5 Knight to f3 knight c6 and Bishop to
b5 the Royal opus 9 to have 6 at the
Berlin defense you know one would expect
a Berlin defense in such an important
game d3 Bishop to c5 so all pretty
standard
we have castles knights to d4 Knight
captures Bishop captures and Bishop to 8
for now c6
c3 pushing the bishop back Bishop to b6
and now nice - a 3 D 6 and
Bishop to c2 and this position was on
the board many times one of the more
stronger players that have had this
position on the board is again between
the Jordan one forest and Peter Lake Oh
the game continued Bishop to g4
attacking the Queen and that game ended
in a draw here Fogg plays Bishop to e6
and I haven't found any positions with
this move in the database so this is a
once again appears to be a new move by
Fabi so an a really nice preparation for
the entire tournament Queen to e2 we
have h6 and team to h1 as the bishop is
on b6 Bobby wants to push f4 we have g5
by Wesley not allowing it and now Knight
to c4 Bishop to see seven nine three
three and now d5 rook to e1 rook to e1
Fabi there was an interview with Fabio
after the game he said he played rook to
e1 because he really couldn't figure out
a way to continue playing this for the
white mostly is already attacking on the
Kings side and you don't really have a
plan here for white here we still played
Queen to e7
we got a four and now a queenside castle
and Bobby said that he was very happy
when he saw the queenside castle because
now at least he knows towards where
should he point his pieces rook to be
one we have d4 attacking the knight and
now Knight to f1 Bishop to b6 and Bobby
says that Bishop to b6 he didn't think
much of this move the idea is that after
C captures Bishop captures he wants to
capture on d4 with the bishop but of
course he's not interested in doing this
he played Bishop to d2 and now we have
Bishop to g4 the idea of D captures on
c3 be captors on c3 and the Knight to g4
now with with some harass on the F to
pawn would be met with knife to e3 so he
wasn't really worried about that after
Bishop to d2 Bishop to g4 now attacking
the Queen f3 pushing the bishop back but
okay
by playing f3 Wesley did provoke a
weakness in White's camp nice the g3 FRB
obviously to put to play his Knights to
h5 and now comes Luke
h/h to g8 and there was a very
interesting line that was mentioned
later in the game about what if black
played h5 but if black decided to give
up the g5 pawn after Bishop captures h4
comes and now this was the whole point
of the of the line if not if if Knight
to f5 then Bishop captures pawn captures
and black plays in D captures on c3 and
after be captures on c3 black has this
very annoying
Knight to h5 idea sacrificing the Queen
Bishop captures and now Knight the g3
the King has nowhere to go
Bishop is guarding g1 you have to
capture the night and then H captors and
g3
will be checkmate after after you give
away the best because there is no other
move which would be a very nice idea the
problem is after this D captures on c3
you don't have to recapture BK person c3
you can simply play Queen captures an e5
you force a trade of Queens and now all
is well for white but an interesting
line to shown and nevertheless so in the
game rook HD g8 by Wesley we have before
Fabia wants to attack on the on the
Queen side g4 now and a5 and here D
captures on c3 Bishop captures on c3 and
rush up to d4 now Bishop captures rook
captures and b5 you know they're trying
to break open the the Queen side c5 of
course
Wesley does not allow that to happened
and the Bishop to b3 now we have h5
Knight to f5 attacking the Queen Bishop
captures pawn captures and rook to e8
now rook beat the c1 pulling that rook
in front of the king and c8 and the King
to b8 would be a very nice move here and
in a lot of other situations in this
game but for some reason Wesley decided
not to play it we have G captures on f3
which Fabi says that there's really no
reason to do something like this
better yet would be definitely king to
be 8 and then if white pushes a6 or b6
you block the position and then you
force a white figure out some sort of a
plan but okay G captures on f3 was
played we have Queen captures and now
rook
to d8 piling up on that d3 pawn Bishop
to c4 defending and E for now this was a
very very nice idea but Wesley and a
very active idea because here I believe
Bobby was down to five minutes or even
less than five minutes and he still had
to make eight more moves to reach time
control so here
Wesley goes for some real activity he
plays efore and i spawned the pawn
sacrifice that will allow him great
activity so he captures on e4 and now
Queen to e5
you know activating his queen but also
giving up another point on f7 so a
bushel captures on f7 and now rook to d3
as the bishop on c4 is no longer
guarding the d3 square now the rook
gains even more activity and the Queen
is pushed back we have Queen today Queen
to f2 and now comes Luke the Arab from
da to d4 Bishop to d5 not allowing black
to capture on e4 and now King to d7
finally getting the rook getting the
King out of that C file has a rocket
presence if I would come with tempo and
here you could definitely play rook
captures on c5 but father was a very
long time and he did not want to leave
the back back rank you know you're down
a time you just grabbed two points you
don't need another pawn
so instead b6 and there were a lot of
moves to consider first he thought about
h3 then he felt nod this is terrible
then rook captures on h3 ideas like that
for coming Knight to g4 that h3 is
really nothing and he couldn't figure
out what to do there and he says himself
he panicked here and he played b6
there's a nothing really happens after
b6 is played the position still remains
the same but there was no need to do
this but okay ways to place a captures
we have a captures and now Knight to g4
and it's very interesting now the queen
is under attack and f2 Queen captures on
h2 this is the threat of course the the
biggest threat of all the threat of
checkmate so only one good move here
Queens you want defending h2 and now
King to d8 everyone thought here this is
more 39 and Wesley wants to reach time
control but also they thought that maybe
this is some kind of
crazy tubes won't move maybe Fabiano
doesn't really have a good move here and
he will simply have to ruin his position
and it's very interesting this is move
of 40 they have to make so far we played
h3 and there was no reason to do it
immediately he could have just waited
play Bishop capture some b7 but this is
something that was only found after the
game was played he did play H 3 and H 3
is something that doesn't work for white
unfortunately but Wesley also dropped to
like a couple of seconds here he almost
lost some time in this position because
Bobby already made move 40 and the
Wesley has to play one more move to
reach time 42 make to reach time control
and make move 40 and so with only a
couple of seconds on the clock you
please
rook captures on h3 well this is in fact
the strongest move recommended by the
engine Fabi does play G captures on h3
attacks the night and here
Wesley now has all the time in the world
he can you know get up from the board he
can stretch his legs a bit and here he
instantly played rook to d3 and roof to
d3 is not a good move tried to find the
idea
Wesley missed here so everything up to
this point was was definitely great why
Wesley but now he misses one idea that
that that he should have played if he
already went for rook captures on h3 so
I will give a couple of seconds for you
to find it
as usual you know just decide for
yourself if you want to do it it's quite
nice so I do recommend you do it so okay
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you just prevented
Fabiano Caruana from winning the 2018
Alti box norway championship and for
those of you who just won injured show
the move he missed
instead of room d3 r up the d2 and now
there is nothing white can do here the
threat of course is rook to h2 both a
knight and queen are guarding that
square and after you play h captures
then comes h capture son g4 and now you
see the problem Queen to h8 is coming
there's really no no good move here
Queen to g2 has to be played to make
room for the king
jiwon and now you don't want to capture
the Queen if you capture the Queen then
comes King captures and there really
isn't
there really isn't compensation here for
black white has two rooks and the bishop
against the Queen and if you try to you
know some if you try some perpetual
checking radius here if five is coming
not the bishop is guarding f3 and there
there is no more draw for black here
capture some have five captures and b7
and there is there is no counter play
for black here so the thing you had to
find after this very nice idea of Queen
to g2 not capturing the Queen but rather
Queen to h8 check and only now when the
King moves and now you capture the Queen
but this comes with check King captures
and now Queen to h3 King moves and now
you have Queen to f3 and now you will
have a very nice perpetual check and
black will draw this game very nicely if
you allow white to escape then a bishop
and two rooks will be much stronger than
the Queen but here it's very interesting
so Wesley makes time control and then
now that he has time instead of Rudy -
he goes rook to d3 and rook to d3 does
make a lot of sense he thought okay if
piano plays H captors and g4 then I'm
gonna go root cap rook to h3 check King
G - and now simply Queen to g3 check
King to f1 and now Queen - a free check
and it's all over Queen f2 and rook to
h1 and this will be checkmate so this
was Wesley's idea but after this rook to
do to remove Fabi play the Queen - G -
and this is the move Fabi saw at the
time he played h3 he saw this position
he didn't saw the whole route D -
business he saw this and he knew that
white was winning so we have rook to g3
here and now H captures on g4 this is
what Fabi had planned
we have rook captures na comes King
capture Sanji - and now h4 King to f3
you don't want to allow Queen to g3
check while the king is an G - so Queen
- a king to f3
King to g3 now we have King - E - now
comes H 3 root 2 G 1 attacks the queen
king or queen moves and outcomes
'if I've HD was played now comes rope to
d1 and after King to e8 or maybe maybe
even this wasn't played I mean it was
played I just can't
can't remember now - what - what
move it was played okay I remember king
of three was played this was played King
e2 was played h3 and rook to g1 okay
Queen h4 a five and I believe after h2
and Ruby one I'm gonna have to check I'm
I'm gonna have to check this let me just
check this for a second
yeah this is sorry about that I was so
excited about this game that I actually
forgot to what move it was played okay
sorry but attacked actually it was here
after the c5 moved that what we saw
resigned the game the reason he resigned
is that there is no way to force
anything here with just the Queen and
the the past H pawn because after h2
after your attack look simply moving the
rook and again black has nothing to do
here you can never capture here because
then Bishop to f3 a defense and also
checks the King so you lose the Queen
here and even if you play something like
King here then Bishop - after he comes
and everything is protected there is no
counter play here white will simply pull
this - - a very nice victory so yeah
sorry about that whole business I really
forgot forgot at what at what point
Wesley so resigned the game but yeah
what's the resigned and Fabiano Caruana
is the 2018 LT box Norway championship
winner and although he started this
tournament
well first they had a bliss tournament
and he didn't do so well and he also
lost the Magnus Carlsen in the blitz
portion and then he also lost his around
one game also against Magnus Carlsen but
he finishes ahead of Magnus Carlsen and
he wins this tournament so as since I'm
already here I'm also going to show you
the the standings this is a live nor
which has the calm web page but it seems
they are using just 24 interface so
we're gonna check out the final
standings here as well so as you can see
Fabiana Caruana with five out of eight
then Carlson in second with four and a
half out of eight Nakamura he car with
four and a half out of eight island also
with four and a half out of eight and
then waste Lisa with four out of eight
since he lost this game Arnold with four
out of eight and then Madera with three
and a half out of eight of a sheer
Allegra with three out of eight and
Sergei kurakin in last place with three
out of eight I believe the circuit
Corrigan was the last head last place
last year as well or or he was tied for
last place with Magnus Carlsen but you
know definitely not not you know maybe
the climate doesn't agree with him or
something in Norway but who could know
so yeah a very nice win for Fabiano
Caruana
and this is the second big tournament he
finishes ahead of Magnus Carlsen first
one being the Greinke chess classic we
also covered that so hopefully you still
remember that and you know it's
definitely definitely going to be you
know a clash of titans when November
comes so yeah this is the final game
will be showing from the 2018 not eBooks
not a championship I do hope you enjoyed
this game and the entire coverage as
well and yeah that's pretty much it hats
off to the winner says Magnus Carlsen
since prior to this game he said that
there is no way he can you know
influence the outcome so he will just
you know go chill on the beach and if if
Wesley and Fabiano draw their games then
there was supposed to be another blitz
tournament that will decide the winner
but since Fabi won this game
he's a clear winner and so hats off to
the winner so yeah thank you all I mean
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and I will see you soon